una sesión maratónica tres días de
debate aproximadamente 20 horas de
discusión con inclusive muchos
inconvenientes a la hora de votar Lo
cierto es que la asamblea nacional no
aprobó la moción de censura al
presidente de la República en Guillermo
lasso y básicamente Y qué es lo que da a
entender esta votación en principio no
se logra la moción presentada para la
descripción del presidente da cuenta de
que existe una alta votación en contra
el primer mandatario en nacional un
aproximado de 47 votos de la bancada el
opositora de unes en la bancada con
mayor votos dentro de La minoría
parlamentaria pero también hay otra
votación la de El Movimiento Político
pachacutí a fin al movimiento indígena
del cual acumula 25 votos
aproximadamente y hay otros votos de
grupos independientes y esto ha
contabilizado una buena cantidad de
votos en ejecutivo nacional hay otra
lectura también lo que sucede por lo
menos el partido social cristiano y la
izquierda democrática
contabilizando aproximadamente hace 15
por una fracción política y 16 por otra
fracción política que rechazan esta
moción Pero qué es lo que sucede bueno
no se ha logrado la votación Así que el
presidente de la república continúa en
el cargo Raúl también Gustavo le digo
que este pedido de instituciones llega
en medio de las protestas como todos lo
sabemos Pues que hemos seguido no este
conflicto en contra del presidente Qué
pasa ahora con una crisis tras la
suspensión de los diálogos entre los
indígenas que lideran estas protestas y
algo ejecutivo
Pero qué pasa hay un factor importante
que se debe realizar recordemos que el
25 de mayo se presentaron entre el
Consejo Nacional electoral unos pedidos
de destitución el presidente de la
república de revocatoria del mandato eso
consejo nacional electoral debe
pronunciarse si esto califica o es
rechazado eso va a suceder el 4 de julio
el Consejo Nacional electoral ha
anunciado que sí debe pronunciarse esa
fecha Y será a través de una revocatoria
del mandado que veía la ciudadanía
deberá decidir si se activa o no este
mecanismo Pero qué pasa continúa la
atención la conade no ha levantado el
paro llama así al diálogo para continuar
luego de que El Ejecutivo nacional
también ha suspendido este diálogo Así
que el día de hoy veremos qué pasa en
las calles lo que continúan
algunas manifestaciones por parte de los
grupos indígenas ra